didn't want it to be this hard  jo Jo Fletcher mites get engaged to  Jordan Rogers or Robbie Hayes on the  Bachelorette and the finale looks like  an emotional roller coaster it's a  really hard day what is it gonna come  down to what is the deciding factor  between Jordan and Robbie you'll have to  wait and see  very good answer a lot happens in that  day so many different emotions so who  will Jojo go with if anyone  well her exes agreed I think she's gonna  pick Jordan after watching it back I  mean he got the first-impression Rose  seeing the connection I had she gave him  first impression Rose and I think that  you know she just looked at him in a way  that was different than a lot of the  other guys and so I think that likely  that's that's the decision are you  engaged I can't say I know I'm staying  I'm staying tight-lipped but I will say  that I am really happy right now